a Zed ran to the segment where I take a
less structured and humorous approach to
look at any topic that crosses my mind
relating to the subject of anime and
manga it contains my raw buys the pin
and it's for the purpose of creating
debate and/or discussion so it shouldn't
be taken too seriously got that great
now shut up and listen a quick glimpse
into the Western anime community will
undoubtedly reveal the popularity of
three shows in particular that will
dominate the plethora of discussions
cosplays and of course online internet
flame wars in the otherwise vast world
of anime I am of course talking about
the shows that have been dubbed the big
three or for those of you that have been
living under a rock and have no idea
what I mean it's Naruto Bleach and one
piece whether you love them hate them
seen them or not you've at least heard
of them since it's pretty much
impossible be a part of the community
without having run into someone talking
about them they are the three shows that
take over the traffic of every manga and
anime site the cosplayers that take over
every convention and are probably the
gateway and may for fans in the West
even for those who don't know what anime
even is however what the popularity
comes a wide varied mix of opinions with
either fans praising the [ __ ] out of it
non fans singing songs of oppa retinas
and everyone in-between starting all out
arguments reminiscent of the fanboy
fights in this generations console war
but why is that what can it be about
these three series I allow them to gain
such popularity why is there such a mix
of opinion in all three of them and why
is it that the mere mention of them is
greeted by reaction of total disdain
from non fans
Naruto tells the ultimate underdog story
of a loud obnoxious ninja searching for
proof and trying to become the leader of
his ninja village advertising smart
fights and a lot of heart in the
beginning but along the way it lost
focus to a [ __ ] teenager trying to way
too hard angst and having battles that
eventually ended up like every other
Shonen where just became a competition
of who could collectively pull off the
most powerful landscape reducing fart
with no real thought of anything else
bleach follows the story of a teenager
thrust into the world of the Soul
Reapers and the battles that happen in
the afterlife having a strong start with
the soul Society of which I still
consider as one of the best shown in
arts out there but afterwards could
never quite get back on track with it
just effectively repeating itself over
and over again without the same Flair
while always introducing characters that
never actually went anywhere one piece
focuses on the adventure of a young
pirate trying to become the Pirate King
and there's a great job at building a
rich world with an immense scale but it
has a very slow start aching around 50
episodes to get good and the rest is
just a balance of some absolutely
fantastic arcs which is countered by
some slow
and sometimes pointless args also
honestly no matter how good you are you
shouldn't have to use up to 500 episodes
to tell a coherent story with an ending
still nowhere in sight and the anime for
all of them with no exception suffer
from a lot of filler all of these shows
are not bad by any stretch of the
imagination but they are far from
perfect and have plenty of competition
in the same genre so it begs the
question of how three noticeably flawed
shows garner such popularity above all
others well the first answer is simple
since it's universally true that just
because something is popular it doesn't
mean that it's necessarily good [ __ ] but
in terms of becoming popular these three
had everything going for them besides
all three of them being extremely
marketable by having the perfect balance
of either pirates ninjas or saarebas
which are just basically death God
samurais they have their lengths as much
less fun at length of downfall and
storytelling it can do nothing but help
with their popularity since as popular
as Death Note Code Geass and gurren
lagaan were back a few years ago they
are a lot less talked about now because
well they've ended well that seemingly
never ending stories of the big three
there's always something new to discuss
something new to watch something to keep
fans coming back and since they'll be
going on for years now those are just
more years for new people to discover
them along their popularity to grow over
time even when shorter anime may have
better stories and that's the thing when
I started getting interested into anime
there was no big three Naruto was the
breakout hit being dubbed as a possible
next gen Dragon Ball Z leaches
popularity was still rising while it
became the hip alternative to Naruto and
one piece was still recovering from the
damage caused by a horrendously bad for
kids dub their popularity has only grown
over time and this never would have
happened if they had already ended which
brings me to my second reason why they
are popular luck while anime are still
growing in the West people look to Japan
as a test of what to watch and besides
from one piece which was always mega
popular Naruto and bleach were just
becoming the next big thing they just
happen to be the most talked about and
spotlighted shows at the beginning of
the internet fueled anime boom that
started in the early 2000s allowing all
of them to be at the forefront for
gateway shows into the Shonan John rrah
which for anime is the most popular the
most talked about and the easiest
introduction for anyone into anime their
popularity on the Internet opens them up
to TV broadcast which only further
cemented them as a big 3 Shonen in other
words for the West at least they were
the right place at the right time which
is why in Japan there isn't even a big
tree to talk about in terms of
popularity it's pretty much as one piece
miles on top then every other shown in
way below it so for people wondering
about their popularity well there's
always going to be something popular it
wasn't these three shows it would have
been something else
and when they end something similar it's
very likely to take over either way with
the popularity came the fandom and with
that a shitstorm of childish arguments
and comments from anyone saying anything
negative about either show or just even
comparing them to the point where if
I'll just to say something in all the
lines of one piece is my favorite out of
the big three I'm pretty sure that
sentence alone is enough to spark a
plethora of dislikes and childish
arguments in the comments section from
people completely missing the point but
I guess that's what I just did yes if
there's one stigma that comes from
mentioning the big three it's
undoubtedly the fan we actually come
from whatever you say about them if it's
not a flood of general abuse it's
something along the lines of well my
character can beat up your character or
this story is so much more deep and
better or that one fight scene is so
much more epic than your fight scene
which judging from his target audience
of teens may be reasonable but why limit
it to three shows I could never
understand the hatred between fans when
it came to the three series with
something like the console wars there
were only ever three consoles to choose
from yes I know there's pcs as well but
shut the [ __ ] up I'm trying to make a
point here so you have to justify your
choice of spending hundreds of dollars
on choosing one of the consoles but with
the big three there are literally
thousands of other anime to choose from
all in different shapes and sizes in the
end this fan attitude is the chords are
pretty much every non fan holding a
somewhat negative opinion of the big
three so much so that they even have
their own names
Tod's but one thing I've noticed in the
callous debate the countless flame wars
the colors rants is that they have Les
Deux of how good the shows actually are
and more to do with the fan base either
finally the need to flame someone for
liking a different one of the big three
or blindly declaring their 1 is the best
show ever and I can only conclude that
this problem stems from a limited
knowledge of the general world of anime
so if there was a general point to this
runs I guess it's just a message to the
big 3 fandom I am NOT saying that the 3
shows are bad in fact there are some
amazing moments in them but everything
they've achieved in the hundreds of
episodes or chapters they have has been
done elsewhere and mostly in a much
shorter time period the underdog story
in Naruto may be good but have you tried
had Jemaine
which has some of the most intense
flight scenes I've ever seen and it's an
anime about [ __ ] boxing the
jaw-dropping saud battles in fate/zero
are better than anything bleach could
ever achieve in its dreams and if you're
just talking about scale going a gun
Trump's one piece just in the sheer size
of things while having the same feeling
of epicness in a mere 27 episodes in
terms of underrated Shonen manga siren
has a more interesting concept and plots
for managing to tell its story and end
without deviating from the tone set in
early chapters and there are literally
thousands of other stuff out there there
you can find at the touch of your
[ __ ] fingertips the fact that these
three are popular doesn't bother me
nearly as much as the fandom since their
popularity is the Gateway for so many
anime fans of this generation and if
there's one thing we can all agree on
increasing the popularity of anime is
always a good thing so where does the
big three stand now well the bleach and
Naruto manga slowly coming to a close
with the Bleach anime already ended and
one piece is still going strong with a
story predicted to be concluded within
the next 10 million years or so what are
they shown in are slowly getting notice
and waiting to take over when their
popularity ends so whether it be the
next fairy tale Shippuden or Tirico Ball
Z there will always be a show or several
shows that hog the limelight and
whatever shows they may be I'm sure it's
inevitable that they will share the same
love hate and passion but haven't given
by this generations anime fans towards
the big three so I'm asking you guys now
what do you think of the big three its
popularity and its fans leave a comment
or video response for your chance to get
featured in my next rats oh and please
don't start arguing over which one's the
best since I have a part two of this
rant coming out very soon with my full
opinion of all three shows where you can
do just that anyway that's it for me now
but with your responses to my last round
video should more anime come back to TV
now the tsunami is back on the air it is
important for it to survive besides
leading money to create new animations
and the dedicated viewership to pull in
ratings tsunami needs new programming to
draw in a new audience so for any of you
who won
menu can she be dead hello cattle
Thailand head he he